pues lo que va en curso y lo que tiene
que ver con el congreso de eeuu es la
reforma migratoria que yo bailé en el
primer día de gobierno dijo que va a
tratar de impulsar en el congreso una
reforma migratoria que tendría que pasar
primero por la cámara de representantes
después por el senado que en este
momento cuenta con un voto más por parte
de los demócratas algo que pone en
riesgo precisamente toda esta reforma
migratoria que quiere llevar una reforma
migratoria bastante ambiciosa y quiere
llevar a cabo el presidente joe biden
entonces lo que le están diciendo a
asesores al presidente yo bailé es que
empiece paso a paso gota a gota a pasar
el artículo por artículo de esta reforma
migratoria en otro tipo de proyectos en
otros en otras leyes que puedan entonces
así avanzar poco a poco este proceso de
reforma migratoria que el presidente yo
bailén ha dicho que si no puede pasar la
d
una de una tacada lo que piensa hacer
entonces es ir paso a paso poco a poco
pero con tal de que haya progreso y
precisamente este progreso es el que
están pidiendo los activistas que le
dicen a bailén que lo apoyaron en su
campaña y que ahora quieren ver
resultados
cristóbal también fue noticia hoy ese
nombramiento en el senado que confirmó a
alejandro mayorkas como secretario de
seguridad nacional ya pitbull ticcih
como secretario de transporte como
reciben esta noticia allí
sí pues con bastante sorpresa reciben y
con mucho entusiasmo muchos activistas y
obviamente los demócratas además porque
6 senadores republicanos votaron para
aprobar a mallorca en el senado
normalmente pues se vota en la línea de
los partidos pero seis republicanos
entonces pues se voltearon de línea y
apoyaron a mayorkas mallorca entonces
con 56 votos se convierte en el primer
latino en liderar el departamento de
seguridad nacional y también en el
primer inmigrante mayorkas en un mensaje
que en el primer mensaje de hecho que le
envía a su personal le dice que no es
importante únicamente pues alcanzar los
resultados sino alcanzarlos con trabajo
con valores con los valores que
representa el partido demócrata y
también le pide que pues sean abiertos
sean transparentes y responsables con
los inmigrantes por otro lado pues
también fue muy bien recibido la
aprobación de pitbulls y jake que se
convierte entonces en el primer
homosexual abiertamente homosexual que
hace
parte de un gabinete presidencial en los
eeuu